Speaker 1: All right.
Let's stick with the Carrie Lake stuff for
a little bit longer.
Carrie Lake lost in Arizona.
She wanted to be the governor.
More people voted for her opponent, Katie
Hobbs.
And Katie Hobbs will be the governor.
A couple days ago, Carrie Lake.
Put out a statement saying we have a lawsuit
and the lawsuit is going to stop certification.
It did not stop certification.
So now Kerry Lake has.
Another lawsuit.
And this one is now that the election is certified,
it was a bogus certification.
So she has a different new lawsuit.
Let's listen.
Speaker 4: Arizona is at the tip of the spear.
We just have an election here November 8th,
which was run like they run elections in banana
republics.
And this is why I'm going to be contesting
the election, as you saw earlier this week.
Some of the I call them clowns running our
circus of elections actually certified the
election.
My opponent, Katie Hobbs, who should have
recused herself but oversaw the election in
a very shady and shoddy way, actually certified
the election.
And a lot of America first patriots were saying,
Kerri, what do you do and why aren't you contesting
this?
What's wrong?
And what they don't realize is that in order
to contest an election in Arizona, it has
to be certified.
So this sham election had to be certified
for us to begin contesting it.
And we will be contesting it.
We're going to be filing our lawsuit on Friday,
and I'll be filling you in more later on in
this program about the lawsuit.
What's coming.
Speaker 1: Up?
Yes, Friday.
Right.
She's going to very, very powerfully inform
us about that.
So a couple of different things.
Number one, earlier in the week, she didn't
mention, by the way, in order to contest that,
it needs to be certified.
The lawsuit earlier in the week was to prevent
the certification.
So let's take a look at that just as a reminder.
Speaker 3: Reasons how possibly can a Republican
attorney general sit there and a governor
sit there and allow this fiasco?
People in Arizona have to understand some
independents and Democrats.
Yeah, you look like idiots on the world stage.
This looks like something that would happen
in the worst.
A banana republics.
Kerry Lake.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
I mean, the optics in just a little over an
hour, the optics of them sitting there and
signing their signature.
Can you imagine to this sham election?
They did it back in 20, 20, two years ago.
And many of us gasped and said, How could
they do this?
Why couldn't they get more time to look into
all of the issues?
Now, fast forward 2020 to today and we've
got more issues than we saw in 2020.
In that sham election.
We have just a blatant sabotaging of Election
Day, a disrespected, disregarded disenfranchisement
of Election Day voters.
That's a.
Speaker 1: Lot of.
Speaker 4: Words.
And if they sit there and sign their names
to this sham certification.
History will never forgive them.
They will go down as as three of the very
worst in history.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So then she went on to explain they have a
lawsuit.
So that lawsuit failed.
The certification took place a few hours later.
Now the next lawsuit is to decertify, which,
of course, is not actually a thing.
This will just go on and on.
And then the next layer to this Kerry like
thing is the God layer.
Let's talk about that next.